>> So, we've reached the end of support vector machines, and
I think we learned quite a bit here.
>> That's right.
At the end of Naive Bayes we started a list of all the different things that we
should be thinking about when picking an algorithm.
We've learned a lot about support vector machines that now we can add on to
that list.
>> Yes. So they work really well in complicated domains where there is
a clear margin of separation.
And they don't perform so well in very large data sets,
because the training time happens to be cubic in the size of the data set.
They also don't work well with lots and lots of noise.
So when the class are very overlapping you have to count independent evidence.
That's where then a Naive Bayes classifier would be better.
>> So again, it comes back to the data set that you have and
the features that you have available.
If you have a really big data set, if you have lots and
lots of features, SVMs right of the box might be very slow.
And they might be prone to overfitting to some of the noise in your data.
>> Okay. Yes, so, just test it out on the testing set.
See how it how it performs.
And then you're ready to go.
>> Exactly.
So, I think we're ready to go on to the next lesson?
>> Awesome.
>> Great.